لا ، نحن بحاجة إلى أسئلة
[موسيقى]
ولكن إذا كان السؤال سيئ التجهيز
وسوء التنظيم وكان الطلاب
عالقين هنا خلال الأيام الأربعة الماضية ،
فلا يمكن الوصول إلى الطعام ولا الوصول إلى
المياه النظيفة ولا الكهرباء ولا شيء ،
وحتى كما نجلس هنا تقريبًا
في كل مكان ، يمكنك سماع طلقات نارية ، فنحن
لسنا بأمان ،
شكرًا لك ،
لذا فإن الأحدث هنا مثل أننا أمضينا أيامًا
دون أن نأخذ عدم وجود حمامات كافية ، ولا مياه كافية ، ولا
ماء ، ولا شيء على الإطلاق ، لا شيء على الإطلاق ، لا شيء ، لا شيء على الإطلاق ، لا
شيء في
مباني الجامعة التي
تعرفونها خارج مقر الجامعة
وما هو  يحدث الأمر وكأنهم
يأخذوننا كحماية كدرع
لذلك لأنهم يعرفون أنه إذا كانوا
بالقرب من الطالب فلن يكون هناك
أي قصف
[موسيقى]